♪ ♪
>> Laura: MARK WAHLBERG AND MO
GIBSON HAVE JOINED FORCES TO
TELL THE TRUE STORY OF AN WRECK
FIGHTER.
OUR OWN RAYMOND ARROYO
INTERVIEWED THEM.
>> Raymond: IT IS A FAITH-BASED
FILM LIKE NO OTHER.
WALBERG, GIBSON, AND THE
WRITER/DIRECTOR TOLD ME WHAT
SETS IT APART AND THEY GIVE US A
GLIMPSE OF THE CHEMISTRY THAT
MAKES IT SO POWERFUL.
WATCH.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF ARTICLES.
I HAVE WRITTEN SOME INTERVIEWS
ABOUT HIM.
YOU WERE DEALING WITH SCANNED
MATERIAL.
HOW MUCH LIBERTY DID YOU TAKE
AND WHERE DID YOU DRAW THAT
LINE.
>> THE BASIC FRAMEWORK OF HIS
LIFE AND THE TRAJECTORY OF HIS
SPIRITUALITY IS ALL TRUE.
WE DID TAKE LIBERTY, ESPECIALLY
WITH REGARD TO TEMPERING.
HE STUDIED IN OREGON AND HE WENT
TO FRANCE AND KEEP WAS FROM ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
BUT YOU CAN'T DO ALL OF THAT AND
THAT WAS OUR BUDGET.
>> Raymond: IT DOES NOT SHOW.
>> IT WAS A NO-BRAINER.
IT WAS VERY STRESSFUL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF IT.
>> YOU GET THE BEST RESULT.
NO PUN INTENDED, UNDER THE GUN.
WE HAD BUT IT SEEMS LIKE FOREVER
TO GET TO THE STARTING GATE.
THAT WE HAVE TO RUSH 30 DAYS TO
SHOOT THE MOVIES.
IT SEEMED LIKE A LONG TIME AND
NOW HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE THINGS.
>> Raymond: YOU HAVE BEEN ROAD
TESTING THIS.
WHAT ARE THEY TELLING YOU?
>> PEOPLE HAVE BEEN OVERWHELMED
AND THAT MOVIE.
EVERYBODY HAS SOME SORT OF
PERSONAL CONNECTION, SOMETHING
THAT IS DRUMMING UP SOMETHING
THAT THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED IN
THEIR OWN LIFE THAT IS VERY,
VERY TOUCHING TO THEM, EVEN THE
MOST CYNICAL OF PEOPLE.
WE WERE TALKING TO A JOURNALIST.
THIS MOVIE WILL TOUCH YOU IN
SOME WAY.
>> Raymond: GOT JOURNALIST, THE
CYNICAL PEOPLE.
>> NOT ALL OF THEM AND RIGHT
AWAY, THEY COME UP TO ME.
ONE GUY HAS TO TALK TO HIS DAD.
TEXTED HIM, THEY WERE HAVING
LUNCH THE NEXT DAY.
ANOTHER JOURNALIST WHO SUFFERED
A LOSS AND SHE WAS -- SHE
THOUGHT SHE WAS OVER IT.
>> YOU AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
[ MUSIC ]
>> PRAY FOR AN EASY LIFE.
♪ ♪
>> YOU CAN'T SAY I NEVER GAVE
YOU NOTHING.
>> Raymond: THIS IS ABOUT A
FAMILY CRISIS.
"FATHER STU" HAS A STORY.
IT IS ABOUT THE KILLING OF A
FATHER-SON RELATIONSHIP AND A
FAMILY COMING TOGETHER THROUGH
PAIN AND SUFFERING.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT SUFFERING
THEME AND THE VALUE AND
REDEMPTIVE VALUE OF THE
SUFFERING AND I WILL START WITH
YOU BECAUSE YOU KNOW A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THIS.
>> CINEMATICALLY AND MAYBE
PERSONALLY.
AND THE HOLY WE RELEASE BECAUSE,
I THINK THIS IS A TERRITORY YOU
KNOW IT WELL.
>> I THOUGHT WHEN THINGS ARE
GOING GREAT AND YOU ARE ON EASY
STREET, THAT IS WHEN YOU MAKE
MISTAKES AND YOU CAN -- YOU
KNOW, YOUR CHARACTER FLAWS COME
TO THE FORE.
IT IS WHEN YOU ARE IN CRISIS
SOMEHOW THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO PULL
THE BETTER PARTS OF YOURSELF OUT
TO DEAL WITH, YOU KNOW, BIG
PROBLEMS AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS
ABOUT SUFFERING, REALLY.
WE ARE ALL DRAGGING SOME SORT OF
BOULDER, SOME SORT OF CROSS AND
IT IS LIKE, IT IS WHEN WE ARE
DEALING WITH THAT STUFF, I THINK
THAT WE ARE OUR BEST.
THAT WAS CERTAINLY THE CASE WITH
FATHER STU.
>> Mark: I THINK EVERYONE IS
HAVING A LOT OF DIFFICULTIES.
WHEN I FOCUSED ON MY FAITH, I
WAS ABLE TO ENDURE AND THAT GOOD
THINGS START TO HAPPEN.
IT MADE IT EASIER AND IT GAVE ME
A LOT OF COMFORT AND PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE THOSE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH A LOT AND I
THINK THAT THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
ALL EXPENSING IS THAT THEY ARE
REMINDED THAT THEY NEED TO HAVE
FAITH AND HOPE AND THAT, YOU
KNOW, LEVEL ENDURES.
>> Raymond: AND HOLY WEEK, IT
BECOMES -- IT IS A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION FOR SO MANY PEOPLE.
THEY ARE BUYING OUT THEATERS.
THEY WANT TO EXPERIENCE THIS AS
ONE.
IT RINGS BELLS FOR YOU.
AS LONG AS WE ARE RINGING BELLS,
YOU ARE DOING "LETHAL WEAPON"?
AND YOU ARE GOING BACK TO
BONNEVILLE?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> Mel: YOU ARE MAKING ME FEEL
-- BUT YEAH, OKAY.
[LAUGHS]
YEAH, I'M GOING BACK THERE.
IT IS GREAT TERRITORY.
UNFORTUNATELY, DONNER IS NOT
WITH US TO HELP THAT PRODUCTION.
HE PASSED AWAY.
HE KIND OF PASSED THE TORCH
BEFORE HE LEFT AND AS A TRIBUTE
TO HIM.
I LOVE THE GUY.
I'M ACTUALLY IT IS AN HONOR FOR
ME TO TAKE THE REINS ON THAT
ONE.
>> Raymond: WHAT DID YOU ALL
GIVE UP FOR LENT?
CANNOT I TRY TO GIVE UP
COMPLAINING BUT IT HAS NOT
WORKED SO WELL.
I'M TRYING TO BE MORE STIMULUS
IN MY EATING HABITS.
>> Raymond: WHAT DID YOU GIVE UP
FOR LENT?
"FATHER STU" I DID NOT GIVE UP
ANYTHING.
--
>> Rosalind: I CANNOT GIVE
ANYTHING UP.
I'M GIVING THIS MOVIE UP.
>> Mel: I'M JUST TRYING TO DO
MOST.
>> Mark: CONTINUED TO PROMOTE
STU'S MESSAGE.
>> Raymond: WHAT DO YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON THIS MOVIE?
>> Mark: EVERYONE IS GOING TO BE
TOUCHED BY IT.
WE ARE ALL DEALING WITH SO MUCH
AND IT JUST REMIND US THAT HOW
YOU HANDLED THESE THINGS AND YOU
HANDLE IT WITH SUCH GRACE AND
DIGNITY.
>> IT IS A POWERFUL FILM.
>> Raymond: IT REALLY IS.
"FATHER STU" HITS THEATERS SOON.
STAY TUNED FOR THE REST OF THE
INTERVIEW.
>> Laura: GREAT INTERVIEW.